welcome back to new rock stars I'm Erik
Bosse and the new Black Widow trailer
unveiled David Harbor as Alexi shots to
go of aka red Guardian aka the first
practical dream bad for most of us who
watch these movies yeah you flex those
Russian tats as the Soviet equivalent to
Captain America there's a lot of odd
history behind this dude and let's call
it out it's kind of nuts to see chief
hopper from stranger things show up in
this role especially considering we'll
spoiler warning for stranger things
season 3 that season ends with a cryptic
tease that hopper did not actually die
he somehow transported to Soviet Russia
and now he could be the mysterious
American in a prison cell referenced in
these season's post credits scene now
the next time we see David Harbor on a
screen he's bursting out of a Siberian
prison cell as they say in Russia what
the you know a lot of Russians speak
English they get confused - look I know
Hopper and Alexei are not the same
character they're from separate
franchises owned by separate Studios
Netflix and Disney who fiercely hate
each other or at least would not benefit
from any kind of bonkers crossover more
do you look into this the more insane
the parallels are so let us detach
ourselves from plausibility and logical
canon and wade into the dangerous but
fun realm of Cannon and our own
imaginations canon to explain how Hopper
could have become black widows Russian
but as part of eight okay let's break
down the timeline
black widows chronology is being left as
a weird mystery we know a part of its
timeline takes place between Captain
America Civil War 2016 and Avengers
infinity war 2018 the two years when the
Tasha Romanoff was on the run after
joining caps team of fugitives defying
Tony Stark in secretary Ross's superhero
Registration under the sokovia accords
but also Black Widow will feature events
from an earlier time period may be
multiple earlier time periods one of
those periods appears to be in the mid
2000s before Natasha joined Nick Fury in
the Avengers initiative born in 1984
Natasha would be in her early 20s during
that time but based on the trailer
footage we've seen the confusion comes
from the footage of Thaddeus Ross D age
so that his hair and mustache are blonde
we learned from in a game trailers that
you can use hair clocks to decode
timelines and we saw Ross in the
Incredible Hulk also set in the mid to
late 2000s with solidly gray hair in
stache so blonde Ross must be at least a
decade earlier probably sometime in the
mid 90s so in the mid 90s
Romanoff would be a teenager likely
still a young initiate in the KGB Red
Room so some of the events of the Black
Widow film must center around other
characters a generation before Natasha
perhaps Rachel Vice as Molina and David
Harbor as Alexei so now let's switch
over to the stranger things timeline
season 3 takes place in the summer of
1985 except for its prologue scene which
takes place in Siberia 1984 the same
year in the MCU Natasha was born
stranger things season 3 ends with
hopper dressed and Soviet military
uniform apparently dying as the portal
opening device explodes but we never see
a body and the post-credits scene shows
a Siberian military prison that contains
some American the theory many of us have
put forward is that hopper did not die
he got sucked into the rift in the
upside down at the last second and at
the upside-down dimension exists
separate from our dimensions
understanding of space creating a kind
of wormhole tunnel between distant
points on our earth allowing hopper to
reappear in Siberia masquerading as a
Russian soldier in the year 1985 so
let's assume that hopper then got
intercepted by Russian patrols and then
interrogated would he give them his name
probably Matt these are the enemy
Russians during a particularly dangerous
time of the Cold War so when pressed for
information about himself wouldn't he
try to blend in as a Russian at first
maybe give them a Russian name that was
most immediately on his mind the Russian
defector he worked with in Hawkins
Indiana was sadly killed named Alexi
okay so hopper as Alexi would be a
valuable asset for Russian intelligence
the guy's a hell of a fighter knows the
ways of the American heartland he also
defeated Gregory their Terminator Ivan
Drago like super soldier assassin who
interestingly possessed superhuman
strength it's not typical for a human
being even a real strong one to be able
to lift an average weight adult male off
his feet by his neck presumably Grigory
was on some kind of rescue roids this is
exactly the backstory of Red Guardian
from the Marvel Comics he was the Soviet
Union's attempt to duplicate Captain
America from the United States an
attempt to steal the elusive Super
Soldier Serum cocktail to create their
own poster soldier to inspire their
military during the Cold War in this
secret military prison income chukka and
stranger things final scene we know they
were doing some kind of scientific
experiments they got a demagogue in
there and all this is presumably for
weapons testing since then Russia during
the Cold War everything listed
new weapons to fight those Americans
could the American hopper slash Alexi be
under a similar kind of experimentation
the development of the perfect spy
assassin super soldier who could be
inserted back into the American
heartland but really serve Mother Russia
based on his ability to punch down a
reinforced steel door Alexi possesses
some superhuman strength and just
imagine overtime from 1985 through the
mid 90s his split loyalties become a
liability the young black widow agency
gets partnered with like the young
milena don't trust this former American
so in the KGB's eyes he becomes damaged
goods so they hide this failed
experiment in a remote prison where he
grows a shaggy beard fills out his dad
bod and covers it in stereotypical
Russian tattoos all until the time
period of Black Widow when Alexi now in
his 50s reunites with some of his old
Black Widow agents who need a split
loyalty rogue for a new mission in
Budapest whether or not the MCU Alexi is
also stranger things hopper trapped in
Russia for decades it definitely is some
interesting backstory to red Guardian
that I'm fascinated to explore a lot of
people are comparing him to the Winter
Soldier program which also included
enhanced super soldiers hidden Siberia
but remember Winter Soldier was Hydra
not the KGB not all dark organizations
are the same perhaps the Red Guardian
program was conducted in conjunction
with the American government and shield
in order to stave off mutual threats
like Hydra similar to the space race
which began as a bitter rivalry between
the u.s. and USSR but later evolved into
an altruistic scientific endeavor in the
80s and 90s Red Guardian could have been
the result of shared research by figures
like Howard Stark
notice that X design on the red
Guardians uniform could read Guardian
had been the mysterious project Exodus
that Tony Stark
alluded to in Iron Man 2 but has never
been revealed in the MCU since and ship
stuff out of storage
everything from projects Pegasus
exhibition Goliath and the Exodus code
name could refer to the Sun and a
departure the exodus of an Indiana cop
to Russia where he was transformed into
a Russian super soldier with split
loyalties now look I'm just having some
fun here I'm not presenting this as a
legit prediction for either black widow
or stranger things season four I'm not a
theory meteorologist here at new
rockstars I'm just pointing out uncanny
parallels between separate properties
that I find interesting
you should too but if you're into this
kind of imaginative thinking and I need
two favors from you Watchers let me know
in the comments below or be it
we what other kind of unrelated
properties could actually be connected
the headcanon it secondly for all the
other naysayers in the comments down
there who are just knee-jerk reacting to
the title and the thumbnail this video
without watching it let them know that
we're just trying something new and
we're playing in the world of
speculation not prediction so to chill
out and to just have an imagination for
once follow me on instagram and twitter
at a boss of all the new rock stars and
socials and remember to subscribe thanks
for joining me bye
[Music]